ciao riverse benvenuti lunghissimo b
spero che avete passato delle bellissime
vacanze che gli stati posati e che
adesso siete carichi per iniziare a
bomba questo nuovo anno scolastico
a tal proposito come tutti gli anni mi
chiedete dei consigli dei suggerimenti
per quanto riguarda la outfit del
famosissimo famigerato primo giorno di
scuola oggi li dividerò in output adatti
per le medie e outfit per le superiori
in entrambi i casi le parole d'ordine
sono semplicità ordine e sobrietà questa
volta nel vero senso della parola prima
di passare ai vari look
vorrei elencarvi quelli che secondo me
sono i look comunque i vestiti da
evitare ricordiamoci sempre che siamo in
un contesto scolastico quindi ci sono
ovviamente delle regole che vanno
rispettate
poi una volta usciti da scuola a fare il
giro e 100 con le amiche a ballare un
rospo vestire come vuole
ecco le cose che io eviterei cappellini
e non so se vale ancora questa regola
quando andavo a scuola io
chiunque si mettesse un cappellino in
testa che fosse il berretto invernale o
il cappellino insomma da baseball veniva
subito rimproverato è invitato a
togliersi lo quindi eviterei non so
adesso sono cambiate le cose però
comunque non è carino secondo me jeans
super strappa e quelli che indosso in
questo momento ovvero li potete vedere
hanno leggermente sul ginocchio uno
strappo ma piccolo piccolo
ok quello lì va ancora bene arrivare
proprio con
i pantaloni stracciate a scuola mi
sembra abbastanza di cattivo gusto
eviterei anche magliette super scollate
e cioè non è il luogo adatto per diciamo
mettersi in mostra
se uno ha un bel fisico un bel seno si
vede comunque anche se un pelino più
diciamo abbottonata passiamo ai look che
io vi suggerisco per quanto riguarda le
scuole medie il primo look che vi
consiglio è un look super semplice in
realtà tutti quelli che vi consiglierò
per le medie sono super semplici perché
non credo insomma che ci sia bisogno di
tirarsi troppo sicuramente è in tutti
questi look c'è il jeans il jeans è
sempre al top è la scelta vincente è
come nero sta bene con tutto su tutto
per tutto
come ho detto prima jeans non strappati
possono essere più larghi più stretti io
personalmente uso con gli stretti quindi
vedrete con gli effetti potete liberi
mettere qualsiasi tipo di jeans sopra il
jeans io indosserei una classica t shirt
un modello di certo normale con la
fantasia che preferite del colore che
preferite
io in questo caso è utilizzata una con
le righe perché mi piacciono ma potere
sei tu a potevo essere le farfalle
quello che più vi piace la vostra
maglietta portafortuna io so che tutte
le ragazzine anche ai tempi avevo con la
maglietta che mi piaceva particolarmente
che mi stava bene e che è dentro di me
pensavo in portasse fortuna
per quanto riguarda le scarpe io
resterei sul comodo quindi una classica
sneaker in questo caso utilizzato le
fila che so che comunque sono molto
usate anche tra i giovanissimi e potete
mettere qualsiasi tipo di scarpa da
ginnastica scarpa bassa il secondo look
è semplicemente un evoluzione del primo
è un'alternativa alla t shirt il primo
giorno di scuola di base in italia penso
che farà caldo però magari c'è gente che
vive in montagna dove fa un po più
freschino e quindi secondo me anche
un'alternativa un'opzione di qualcosa
insomma un po più caldo ci sta in questo
luca al posto della t shirt o sopra t
shirt indossa un maglioncino
in questo caso con lo scollo a v io l'ho
indossato in questo modo ma potete
benissimo anche metterci una camicetta
sotto molto brava ragazza molto college
ma essendo look super classico va sempre
bene quindi andate sul sicuro
terzo look lo chiamerei il boscaiolo
sapete la mia passione per le camicie a
quadri sopra il jeans ho indossato
questa camicia rosa quadri di
abercrombie secondo me molto carina
molto adatta insomma alle medie è un
look molto basic ma con quella nota
appunto di rosa di femminilità e di
fashion che secondo me è perfetta
un'altra opzione potrebbe essere sempre
utilizzando la camicia ma in questo caso
come giacchetta quindi una t shirt basic
una canotta non troppo scollata e la
camicia sopra appunto come fosse una
giacchetta oppure se avete caldo legata
in vita è un look che a me piace
tantissimo che forse avevo già proposto
nel vecchio school di qualche anno fa e
secondo me è veramente carino fresco e
adatto per il primo giorno di scuola
passiamo alle superiori per il primo
look optato per una gonna jeans lunghina
ovviamente come ho detto prima non gonne
corte questa qua arriva più o meno al
ginocchio poco poco sopra quindi secondo
me è adatta a quello che abbinerei a
questa gonna è una t shirt un topino
l'importante che ovviamente non si vede
la pancia di fuori che è proprio
bruttino a scuola per quanto riguarda le
scarpe utilizzato di nuovo le fila che
secondo me stanno benissimo su questo
look essendo look molto basic potete
benissimo sbizzarrirvi con catherine
ciondoli braccialetti ovviamente niente
di opulento niente catenazzi al car dib
però comunque qualche accessorio secondo
me valorizzano ulteriormente l'outlet
magari anche un cerchietto quello che
volete
il secondo look è un look che
personalmente mi piace un sacco e che è
molto simile insomma ai miei look da
liceale ho utilizzato un pantalone a
palazzo in questo caso color salviamo in
giro lo trovate ovviamente di tutti i
colori e abbinato a questi pantaloni un
una magliettina una t shirt nera per
rendere un po più rock
il look ho aggiunto una cinturina che ho
preso da zara nera con le borchie oro
quindi il tocco oro nero che non manca
mai
per quanto riguarda le scarpe o
utilizzato degli stivaletti bassi non
esagererei con il tacco ognuno di voi è
libero di abbinarci e scarpe che
desidera secondo me in questo caso uno
stivaletto nero ci sta molto bene il
terzo look è il più sportivo quindi per
tutti coloro che amano la comodità anche
a scuola ho utilizzato un pantalone
della tuta in questo caso di ciniglia ma
potete utilizzare il pantalone che
preferite abbinato un topino in questo
caso bianco potete utilizzare anche una
t shirt più larga che dia un effetto
ancora più sportivo e se volete potete
aggiungere una femmina in vita che in
caso abbiate freddo potete anche
utilizzare come felpa punto tassative le
scarpe da ginnastica ultimo look è super
carino super modaiolo ma anche molto
anni 90 infatti io lo amo super pink più
pink di così c'è solo peppa big è un
completo formato da gonna di jeans e
giubbotti no over quindi super largo
appunto molto vintage sottomesso una
canotta bianca non troppo scollata
potete metterci ancora t shirt dentro la
gonna quello che preferite
ho utilizzato anche qui
le fila quindi le scarpe bianche che
appunto si abbina la maglia questo
sicuramente il look più sofisticato un
po più pensato sicuramente vi farete
notare però non penso che sia né volgare
né esageratamente eccentrico quindi
potrebbe essere anche questo super
adatto all'occasione come sempre spero
che i miei consigli vi possano tornare
utili e che magari possiate ispirarvi a
uno di questi look o copiare uno di
questi look per il vostro primo giorno
di scuola
fatemi sapere con un commento qui sotto
quali di questi look avete preferito e
mi raccomando mandate le foto dei vostri
outfit su instagram con un direct
se volete qualche piccolo consiglio
anche su make up e acconciature per il
primo giorno di scuola
io vi consiglio di aspettare il prossimo
video
se questo video vi è piaciuto mi
raccomando mettete un light
iscrivetevi al canale se non l'avete
ancora fatto perché per me è
importantissimo far divertire e far
arrivare i miei video a più persone
possibili e seguitemi su tutti gli altri
social facebook in ser
i tic toc e vi mando un bacione grande e
ci vediamo al prossimo video
[Musica]